- Welcome back.
We've got Andrew Rannells
and Josh Gad with us.
Give it up everybody.
(audience cheering)
So their new Broadway show
is called "Gutenberg The Musical"
and since we are all
obsessed with Broadway,
now would be a nice time to talk about
some of our other favorites in life.
This is called Obsessions.
- Obsessions.
- Obsession.
(people laugh)
- Andrew did it with you. (laughs)
That's right.
It is time to own up to our obsessions.
Weird or not, for the first time
in our New York City studio.
I love bringing...
(people cheering)
I'm gonna hit this button
and a topic will be selected
by super random super computer,
which apparently followed us from LA.
Then the person obsessed
(people laugh)
with the topic will own up
and sell us on their obsession.
I will get us started. Here we go.
(button dings)
Okay.
(graphics chiming)
(Kelly gasps)
- Oh.
- [Audience] Oh.
- I'm out.
- I share this obsession.
- You?
(audience laugh)
Are we gonna do it next season?
You wanna join?
- I will happily be
- You wanna join?
in your fantasy football.
- Oh my God. Oh my gosh.
We should do it.
It's my first season. I'm obsessed.
Lester happened to kick my behind
this last weekend.
- Oh.
That's okay, still plenty
- But I didn't
- of time.
- really know the players
as well, and now I'm obsessed.
Now I'm like watching
- Yep.
- Games that were on weeks ago
just to study up.
(audience laugh)
- Yeah.
- Wow.
You're really...
you're going deep.
- I'm really into it
because I like a game.
You see Andrew?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and fantasy
- See he keeps...
- football's fun.
- He keeps trying to get
me to watch the sportsball.
- I will literally...
- His sportsball. Yeah.
- I'll be on Sundays,
our show starts at three.
- Uh-huh.
- I'll be backstage
watching on my iPad football games.
- Absolutely.
- And Andrew will walk by
and go, you watching sportsball again?
(audience laugh)
- Exactly.
- I couldn't do it this year
- Wow.
- because I'm so committed to work.
(people laugh)
- Yeah, you're very focus.
- And so I haven't.
- You're very focused.
- Well, I'm not committed
to work and I was like,
(people laugh)
"I'm doing it."
- Yeah.
- I'll play your
fantasy game.
- Will you play sports?
- All right. Perfect.
- Yes. It's so fun.
If you like a game.
Anyway, okay, it's next.
- Oh gosh. Oh God.
- Oh, I don't...
- Oh, I'm getting it
'cause I'm controlling.
- Got it.
Okay. Perfect.
(people laugh)
- Videos of the being brushed?
- I'm gonna admit this.
- Ooh.
- This is...
- My girls.
- [Andrew] This is very specific.
- My girls got obsessed with videos
of animals being brushed.
And I was like, this is
the weirdest obsession.
And then I got sucked into it.
(people laugh)
So we now...
- What kind of animals?
- Okay.
- Oh, I...
- [Audience] Aw.
- [Josh] Thank you.
- Oh my God.
- That's all it takes.
It's an obsession now.
So my wife and my girls and I,
every day we send each other videos
of animals
- I didn't know this
- being brushed.
- about you.
- Well...
- So there's like a little bit
of like a transference,
like an ASMR situation.
- Okay. Okay.
- It calms you down.
- This is my way of telling you.
"I wish you would brush me occasionally."
- Aw.
(people laugh)
Joshie, I'll brush you.
Yeah.
- Just a little comb.
- Yeah, I can brush your hair.
(people laugh)
- Andrew, you can do the button.
- Oh, I get to do it.
- What happened?
(button dings)
(people laugh)
(graphics chiming)
- I touched it. Oh, minus...
(graphics chime)
- Yeah. Okay.
- Okay. Oh.
- Oh. All right.
I can get behind that.
- This is recent for me.
- Crockpot, did you like
a one pot?
- This is recent for me.
I'm obsessed.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
Well, I'm...
- You just throw it all in.
- You just put it in there.
Even if you don't have a Crockpot kids.
- [Kelly] Wait, what?
- You can use like a, you know,
- A microwave
- A dutch oven.
- Okay.
- Or you know...
- Yeah.
- No, not a microwave.
- Now what's a Dutch oven to you?
- Well, it's like
- 'Cause a dutch oven...
of those like Le Creuset.
(blows raspberries)
This is taking a trip.
(people laugh)
It's like a cast iron pot.
- Okay.
- That you can put
everything in.
- Oh boy.
- Okay.
- Yes.
But a Crockpot,
I'm from Nebraska.
- Yeah.
- We like a Crockpot.
- Yeah, and a dutch oven apparently.
(people laugh)
- Kelly Clarkson.
- It's very different.
- I love that you needed to qualify it
with a quality Crockpot, like as if
- A high quality Crockpot.
- there was confusion that
you wanted garbage Crockpot.
- It's hard to do a garbage crock.
That's the thing about Crockpot.
See, I don't like
cooking, but you throw it
all in,
- You put it all in there.
- Spices, it's pretty good.
- And then walk out.
- Yeah.
- I'll give you some recipes.
- Yeah, I'm a lazy cook. This is my vibe.
- Yeah.
- This is perfect.
- I'll send you some
- All right.
- recipes.
- Don't lie. Send it to me.
- Oh, I'll do it.
- Okay, okay. Here we go.
(button dings)
(graphics chiming)
Okay, I'm hitting it.
- All right.
- What do you got?
What do you got?
(graphics chime)
- Oh.
- Whoo.
- Do you love it? Do you love it?
Do you love it?
- Yeah.
Obsessed.
- Yes.
- Obsessed.
- I mean, it's the greatest
show on TV right now.
- Yeah.
- It really does.
- Like...
- [Josh] Can I admit something?
- Yes.
- I went to the white room
last week on stage.
(Kelly gasps)
- Well...
- I went to
Steve Martin white room.
- Did you reenact
Steve Martin in the thing?
- Well, no, what happened was,
so in "Only Murders In The Building,"
Steve Martin goes to the
white room where you blank
when you're in performance
and you are suddenly out of your body.
- Yeah.
- And I grabbed the wrong hat.
There's like one hat that I'm not supposed
to touch in the entire show
and I found that I was holding it,
but I never remembered picking it up.
I totally went to the white room.
- Like at times in the "Book
of Mormon," we were like six,
eight months in and you'd
forget something that you did.
- It was wild.
- Three times a week.
And you were like, how am I forgetting
this now for the first time?
Because you...
- But it's kind of fun.
- You know why?
You were thinking about
quality Crockpot recipes.
(people laugh)
- I was thinking about that.
- And he was playing fantasy football
- And he was probably playing sportsball.
- Sportsball.
- Okay,
it's your turn.
- Thinking about his teams.
- Do I get to this time?
- Yes.
This time, just the one time.
(people laugh)
(button dings)
(graphics chiming)
- What do we got?
- What, it doesn't even
light up for me.
- [Kelly] No, it's a rough
budget. It's a rough budget.
- Oh, sure, sure, sure.
- Internet rabbit holes
- Yeah.
- after watching "The Crown."
- I hear you on this one.
- I watched "The Crown."
- Yeah.
- I've never seen that.
- I literally...
- Oh, it's so great.
- Forget it, I go down a rabbit hole
- Yeah.
- Of researching the events
of "The Crown" that I just watched.
- What's true, what's not true.
- So the Romanovs,
- I do that. Sure.
- everything I knew about the Romanovs
was from Fox's animated
"Anastasia" musical.
- Oh my gosh. It's so great.
- Knew nothing else.
- Yes.
- So I watched this...
- It's a little different.
- I watched an episode of "The Crown."
It's very different
- Yeah. Yeah.
- in the animated
- Yeah, oh, yeah.
- "Anastasia" movie.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yes.
- Spoiler alert,
she didn't survived.
(people laugh)
- She's dead.
- So I learned this
- from "The Crown."
- Yeah, she is...
She's doesn't sing "Journey to the past."
- No, she doesn't sing much.
- She's gone.
- Dancing (indistinct).
- But that's, I hear ya. I do the same.
Any sort of historical...
- Yeah.
- Yeah, you're like
is that true?
- (grunts) I must know
if they're lying to me. It
- It makes me realize
how much I was not paying
attention in high school
that I know nothing about.
- Oh.
Isn't that weird that later in life
you really enjoy history,
but like, when you're supposed
- True, yeah.
- to be learning it,
you're like, this is boring.
- If it was on a TV show.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I would've been hooked.
- Exactly.
- But yeah,
I get that one.
- Now they're doing both.
That was a great soundtrack,
by the way, "Anastasia."
- Oh, great. Sounds so great.
- Oh, so good. Okay.
And those were our...
- Obsessions.
(audience cheering)
The duet that Jesse and
Andrew are having is nice.
Okay, Josh and Andrew's
- I just wanna help.
new Broadway show is called
"Gutenberg the Musical."
Go see it playing now until January 28th.